is there advice you have for
how to achieve focus
on a task
yes
first of all we have to distinguish
between modulators and mediators and
i'll do this very briefly there are a
lot of things that will modulate your
state of focus but they don't directly
mediate your sense of focus so for
instance if right now a fire alarm went
off in this building it would modulate
our attention we would get up and leave
it'd be very hard to do what we're doing
with that banging in the background at
least at first
so it's modulating focus but it's not
really
involved in the mechanisms of focus
right
in the same way being well rested when
you sleep your autonomic nervous system
that adjusts states of alertness and
focus and calm works better than when
you're sleep deprived so if you're
sleeping better you're going to focus
better so i always answer this way
to a question like this because
the best thing that anyone can do for
their mental health physical health and
performance in athletic or cognitive
endeavors or creative endeavors is to
make sure that you're getting enough
quality sleep
enough of the time for you and that's
going to differ we could talk about what
that means now in terms of things that
mediate focus
without getting in the description of
mechanisms because we have podcasts
about that
it's very clear that mental focus
follows visual focus provided that
you're a sighted person
much of the training that's being done
now in china to teach kids to focus
better literally has them stare at a
target
blinking every so often but really
training themselves to breathe calmly
and maintain a tight visual aperture
when you read you have to maintain a
tight visual aperture you're literally
scrolling like a highlighter in your
mind's eye right it's kind of obvious
once you hear it so for people that have
problems focusing sleep well
learn to dilate and contract your visual
field consciously this can be done
if you practice it a little bit and then
be as i said before it is very hard to
get into a state of focus like a step
function immediately like snapping your
fingers what you can do is you can pick
any object but ideally an object at
roughly the same distance
placed it roughly the same distance to
which you're going to do that work and
stare at it you're allowed to blink and
as your mind starts to drift every once
in a while to understand that's normal
but try and narrow your visual aperture
and bring that into your
visual field so that that's the most
prominent thing kind of like portrait
mode in your phone this would look very
different in portrait mode than it would
in just a standard photograph mode
and then after doing that for 30 to 60
seconds
moving into the work that you're about
to do and really encourage yourself to
do that
if you're somebody who's low vision or
no vision you're going to use your ears
to do this braille readers have trouble
focusing sometimes because they feel
other stuff and they hear other stuff
so you learn to adjust that aperture
consciously
and then of course the pharmacologic
tools just enough caffeine but not too
much right
we've talked about white noise brown
noise music or no music really varies
but it's very clear that binaural beats
of 40 hertz
can shift the brain into a heightened
state of focus and cognition so if
you're going to use binaural beats which
should definitely be used with
headphones
and their number of free apps out there
in sources uh 40 hertz seems to be the
frequency that
best supports the brain shifting into a
particular can you give us the some some
some binaural beats yeah so you're going
to look for you'd want to find a
an app that offers 40 hertz i think
brainwave
allows you to um
slide bar up to the particular frequency
that you want and i should say that
there are other frequencies that are
interesting but 40 hertz binaural beats
seems to be the one that there's the
most quality research on so there's a
it's like it's like a b yeah oh yeah
yeah but you're saying there's a lot of
mixed science on the on the yeah brought
white noise and brightness you really
should be doing this with headphones
because binaural beats are best
accomplished by feeding two different
frequencies to the two ears and then you
have what's called the this brainstem
area that reads out what are called
interaural time differences and then it
extracts the
the delta essentially turn up
and then in other things that can
enhance focus so you know the
pharmacology around this is pretty
interesting things that tickle the
dopamine pathway and the acetylcholine
by the way they work yeah um there's
your ritalin your adderalls your
modafinils which are prescription and
there's a lot of
non-prescription use of those
prescription drugs not so much in my
generation but in people 35 and younger
you know i hear all the time from day
traders and programmers and stuff and
kids that play video games a lot of
ritalin adderall use
i think that unless it's prescribed by a
doctor for its specific purpose of adhd
i don't think people should go that
route frankly hits the dopamine system
way too hard also
has a number of negative effects on
sexual side effects all sorts of things
that you just wouldn't want
there are a few compounds like alpha gpc
um 300 milligrams to 600 milligrams of
alpha gpc with a cup of espresso if
you're well rested you're like a laser
for 90 minutes maybe two hours but then
it's going to taper off and you have to
just recognize that and then there's
this whole world of nootropics now and
people trying to figure out that
racetams paracetams and phenol
ethylamine combined with this and you
know it's not quite in the place where
you'd like it to be there are a few
companies that are doing this better
than others we talk about some of these
on the podcast but um
i would always start with behavioral
tools and then consider pharmacology and
and then i suppose the the other thing
for focus is um they're these this is a
little more esoteric but uh we cover
this in an episode on workplace
optimization um where you place your
screen is important staring down at a
screen is not going to be as effective
as placing it at eye level or above you
when the eyes are up literally your eyes
are directed forward or up the brain
stem centers for alertness are activated
when your eyes are down it's actually
you're you're sort of it's like being
pulled under water a little bit in the
autonomic arousal sense it's you're
closing your eyes i mean um
is one
it reflects the brain stem centers that
are active becoming less refrec for
alertness excuse me becoming less active
but there's a really cool effect that's
active in this room right now which is
that there's been some really
interesting studies that when people
work in small compact spaces or wear a
hoodie or a hat that can also
improve focus like blinders on a horse
for obvious reasons now based on what i
said before but also
analytic work or the kind of work where
there's a correct answer that you're
seeking
is best supported by these kind of low
ceiling environments whereas there's
something called the cathedral effect
which is when you work in an outdoor
environment or a high ceiling
environment it lends itself to kind of
pun intended kind of loftier ideas and
more creativity and that probably has to
do with the fact that there's a natural
tendency a reflex to expand your visual
field in these high ceiling environments
expansion of the visual field
changes the way the brain works in the
time domain your engineering and biology
oriented
listeners will understand this and music
for those that don't
the best way to think about it is when
you have a narrow focus portrait mode on
your phone or you're very alert you are
fine slicing life in time it's like a um
think of it as a high frame rate like
you're shooting in slow motion
when you have a uh when you dilate your
v your view you're taking bigger time
bins and the one way to just let this
hopefully land home is that if you've
ever had a really exciting day or
podcast interview or experience of any
kind your system is flooded with
dopamine and norepinephrine alertness
and motivation all this excitement it
seems like it goes by very very fast and
yet when you think back to that it seems
like a lot happened this happened and
that happened now think about waiting in
the doctor's office in a blank waiting
room with no interesting art on the
walls
it feels like it goes by very very slow
dopamine and norepinephrine are all time
low
and yet when you think back on that
experience it's as if nothing happened
because you were
you were parsing time differently so
those are the roughly the tools and the
and the neurochemicals around time
perception and the time domain uh
there's a wonderful book i'm forgetting
the title so wonderful i forget the
title by dean umano from ucla i think
it's called the brain is a time machine
that talks about this expansion and
contraction of the time domain and what
you can do to leverage it for work and
creativity focus and so on yeah it's
fascinating that i think one way to
define focus for me is
uh to the experience the feeling of
focus is losing track of time
is getting to a place where you're no
longer up
operating in time
well and you mentioned being you know
kind of uh cramming for for something
well you'll release a lot of adrenaline
and you'll it is true you can get a lot
done under pressure because of the way
that you're slicing time you don't
actually have more time it's that you're
finally in a brain state that lends
itself well to
parsing information really quickly now
if we ramp up your level of stress
enough it's definitely a you know it's a
more or less normal distribution we get
you stressed enough it's hard to
remember anything you're not parsing
time well but in that middle range
almost every study shows that the higher
levels of autonomic arousal meaning
norepinephrine adrenaline in your system
the more effective you are at things and
you know we always hear stress and
adrenaline it's just bad bad bad but my
colleague ali chrome at stanford has
done these beautiful studies where if
you just educate people on how
adrenaline makes them
sharper thinkers
they become sharper thinkers if you
educate them on the fact that stress
makes your cognition worse their
cognition gets worse this is why i don't
wear a sleep tracker if you tell people
they slept poorly your recovery score
sucks
they naturally perform less well the
next day than if you tell them your
recovery score is high and so i don't
have anything against those companies
but i in fact i we use some of their
technology can be very useful in certain
contexts but
you want to determine your
your mindset around these things and if
you tell yourself hey deadlines make me
sharp pressure makes me sharp you will
perform better
you